Speaker 1: Let's go next to let's go to
Jonathan from Arkansas. Jonathan, welcome.
Speaker 2: Hello? David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Yes, I was. I had a question
about the Arkansas governor race as it looks.
He looks here living in Arkansas that Sarah
Huckabee Sanders is will probably be the will
probably win the governor's race.
Speaker 1: It does look that way.
Speaker 2: And, you know, do not want her to win
at all. Right. I was just wondering if you have
any advice. Cause if you think as you go
forward. For. For the Republican. WASHBURN
Or if that's true, just because voting for
a Democrat will be a vote thrown away here
in Arkansas, because I do not think Chris
Jones will be able to beat the Republicans.
Speaker 1: Well, but hold on a second. Sarah
Huckabee Sanders earlier this week won her
primary. So she's going to be on the ballot.
And then Jones, the Democrat, will be on the
ballot. But you're saying there will be another
Republican on the ballot in November as well.
Speaker 2: Yes.
Speaker 1: Oh, why? That doesn't make sense to me.
Is it a write in campaign or something?
Speaker 2: Oh, no, no, never mind. I
was talking about the libertarian.
Speaker 1: Oh, libertarian. Listen,
vote for whoever you agree with the most. Okay?
That's my advice to you. You can decide in terms
of the strategic aspect of who to vote for. But
I would just tell you, vote. Vote for whoever you
agree with the most. Because, quite frankly, it
just seems like Sarah Huckabee Sanders is going to
blow out the wind, you know?
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Sadly, sadly.
Speaker 2: Sadly. Yeah. I mean,
do you think there's anything I could do or
do you think is is the that's the reality?
Speaker 1: No, listen, I mean, I don't think it's
worth giving up. She should be challenged as much
as possible. If she's going to win, make
her spend as much money as possible to win.
Make it as difficult as possible for her to
win. So I would figure out, do you prefer the
Democratic or the Libertarian candidate?
You can phone bank, you can get involved,
you can doorknock it, make it as hard for her as
possible. And we have to recognize it's an uphill
battle because Arkansas is such a red state yet.
Speaker 2: Yes. All right, David, I'll let you
go. Thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you,
Jonathan from Arkansas. Yeah, it's a tough,
tough, tough situation there. All right.
Thank you to everybody who called in. We are not
going to be able to speak to anyone else today,
but we will speak to more people again. We'll
go to a quick break and be back right after this